crab feast you know it's all about this
is the crab see I'm telling [ __ ] that
you ain't got a half me could you could
trust that every to see you already know
or I integra socks off you go
above-ground pool goes better than most
J Larkin self-diagnose go download this
week last week and we don't get [ __ ]
or crappy Oh
[Music]
oh yeah welcome back to the crab feast
y'all had to be here no the Tuesday
crappy so that is all over register
there this morning hey man are down this
morning no no it's technically afternoon
I didn't afternoon hi morning I have to
do an evening is great to be here with
the jail aw sweet I'll be here with you
sickle cell official so what's up
feature nation Jay Larson over here Jay
Larson comic com is my website Jay
Larson comic com on all social media
every Wednesday meltdown comics rabbit
hole I'll be there if you're in town
please come april 9th i'll be at UCB on
sunset at 9pm which is going to be a
great show if you're around please come
out San Francisco Bay cluster fest June
first through the fourth recording this
is not happening on june sixth in los
angeles it's going to be a great show
june twelfth of headlining is that you
that's may May twelfth my bad headlining
the Hollywood improv come up to that and
then all the way out in October I'll be
in la jolla and then end of july i'll be
in dublin again for the dublin comedy
festival i don't how many of you going
to be in dublin but if you if you've
been wanting to go to Ireland make a
trip out it's a great festival sickle
cell Ryan Sickler on all social media
Ryan Sickler calm I to have something on
Wednesday nights go to the rabbit hole
at eight o'clock and then after the show
get home and check out the comedy jam on
Comedy Central every wednesday at ten
you can also catch full episodes at CC
com love seeing you guys catch that
hashtag FTC f up on the wall always a
producer over there met him see the
unbelievably may 12 to 13 Portland with
Tom Segura I'm a 18 through the 20th the
crap shoot comedy festival in vegas and
way down the line in September I'll be
headlining the La Jolla Comedy Store the
crab feast calm for all crab feast info
your merch is there amazon please
continue to
is that link if you have and I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're wait yeah sake
we say don't every goddamn intro premium
apps are there you are get wet and make
sure you follow the crab feast on
facebook and twitter and tweet or some
great this is one of the most
interesting sponsors i think we've ever
had called talks pay love it i don't
know if you guys are familiar with talk
space but basically it's an online
therapy company so talk space makes it
easy for you to connect with a licensed
therapist hand-picked just for you for
as little as thirty two bucks a week i
don't know if any of you've ever gone
out out there to to a therapist or a
psychoanalysis or a what's the one
psychiatrist you know there's all
different kinds of ending Garrity to a
week is definitely not 32 a week so what
you can do is using talk space you can
text you can audio or video message of
therapists and talk about your life
what's keeping you up at night or even
your annoying co-worker which to be
honest some of the most beneficial
aspects of therapy from what I've
experienced is just being able to [ __ ]
about life anything because I think you
and I know because we both have our
lives are a train wreck at times and
amazing at times you don't want to be
bitching to your friends you don't want
to be bitching to your wife or your
husband or your mom or your dad you want
to pay a professional you can go and
just spit at for an hour and they have
to listen to relationship save or
personal business friends or whatever it
is a hundred percent and and a
professional point of view and
perspective you may not have thought of
or going from your friends who just want
to be encouraging like yeah [ __ ] that
guy you know exactly thanks for I've
very good point the talk space is I mean
this is I mean this is what it is you
most your communications being held
through text or your phone or FaceTime
anyone nowadays so sign up or learn more
go to talk space.com slash crab and show
your support for the crab fees use code
crab see our a be to get thirty to
thirty dollars off your first month
that's crab at talk space.com slash crab
and I'm just going to say this to anyone
who's ever user not use this is a great
intro into the therapy world for people
who have never done
I did when I left near came back to LA
at a therapist in New York and we did
phone therapy for months and it was so
beneficial you think you need to be
face-to-face you don't you just need
that person be listening I mean they
might be texting on the other end I
don't think these you're getting it out
yeah exactly and if I could just add to
that actually there are a lot of people
that are uncomfortable with the face to
face and therapy and general I'm common
comfortable you right now it's a great
way to do it over the phone and you know
this podcast has been very much therapy
for a lot of yeah you guys send to so
many great emails about the tough things
you're going through so you know thank
you for listening and laughing with us
but there's an opportunity for you to
get some professional perspective on
your problems that don't just put them
on pause with laughter make you feel
better another great sponsor ProFlowers
have you ever forgotten or anniversary
if you're not and yes like a lot of you
are I'm sorry if you're not nodding yes
like a lot of you are you're lying you
know those people that are just hard to
shop for like your wife or your
anniversary or sister for her birthday
it's just the worst trying to find the
guardian sorry miss that a you know they
like and be won't cost an arm and a leg
well I'm going to make it easy for you
ProFlowers is our go-to flowers they're
fresh their price right and they're
perfect gift for literally anyone and
they get delivered straight to the
recipient store how easy is that right
now proflowers has a special offer just
for our listeners you get ten dollars
off your purchase of twenty nine dollars
or more this deal works on best-selling
gifts like they're one hundred blooms
bouquet a dozen red roses or even
they're totally unique plant gifts to
snag this great deal just go to
proflowers.com and enter our code crab
CRA be at checkout you know i just i
just ordered some flowers for Stella I
wanted them in the house she likes him I
got him shipped and what are they
guaranteed their time they're guaranteed
for seven days or your money back there
he had lasted two weeks I've never got
proflowers that didn't last for more
than 70 left yet two weeks they really
did my daughter loves them she checks
him out every day I'm gonna start
keeping them rolling fresh on the table
all the time like I said they're
guaranteed fresh for seven days or your
money back from France
how they have a seven-step quality check
which means the flowers are always
awesome their website is super easy to
use here's a great thing you can
schedule your delivery ahead of time so
right now if your anniversary is in
September you can get it done right now
while you're listening to the feast go
online boom set it up you won't miss it
hands there you go eat your outside of
the press yeah it's any date you want
and get back to your day proflowers is a
no brainer gift for birthday anniversary
every occasion or even no occasion at
all just because any time when you
wanted to feel special they take care of
all the details do yourself a favor and
help out our show by supporting
proflowers i know you have either a
birthday or anniversary coming up so
right now get ten bucks off your
purchase of twenty nine dollars or more
at proflowers but this deal definitely
won't last long go to proflowers.com
enter code crab a check out to get the
special deal i'll tell you what will
last is this episode it's good it's a
doozy we love this guy we're love to
have them back on the podcast please
welcome back to the crab feast mr. Dave
Anthony whatever growling oh god I
forgot we applaud I forgot loud i forgot
to get really loud oh you know where
they don't wear headphones you throw
them violently now that's right you
don't do that you know that I don't do
this and he throw them down I mean I
have my own ways of doing things one of
the things that I do is I try to
intimidate the host yeah well we're not
intimidate somebody over here needs QC
it's really what these are all about
let's make sure you're up on that mic
and you look like it you look good dude
and now I've put on I lost weight now
put it back I do it all the time [ __ ]
whether I put on what cuz you again I
can't sit with my kid all the time
hearing home germs always do it's the
worst so then I can't die then I'm just
sitting around I'm like all those
Cheetos was good and then I'm fat yeah
totally well before we get into your
fatness why don't we talk about your
social media your podcast long evening
well I you booking dry well I feel
happening around here no you're not to
wear though there is Jesus I ran into
dave at the acc get-together slash my
party / new studio something exciting is
that I got to come back on and say like
10 G's I'm making no Nick corner me he
just threw it out there is small talk
but I called him one is bullsh
yet that I had sent him an email saying
i want to come to your your stand-up
taping and i wanna and i want to do the
pot yeah again and he didn't respond
because he was too busy and then he sang
back and he sent me an email afterwards
apologizing and I was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] ison no I just forgot to respond
but I gone for a while we would love we
love these on all the Sun we just had
Gary oh that's nice to hear appreciate
that man Gary and you were both on the
crab feast recently here double ended up
he's making the podcast rounds right now
that little [ __ ] it's like you guys are
going on tour or something I planned it
or not a nice however you want to say it
I like Iceland right so I'm sitting at
home and there's a thing called secret
flying com secret flying online don't
[ __ ] tell anybody I follow them on
the Instagram and they just and they
just what basically do is they find
computer errors in the system and they
go you can buy these right now dude and
then they have to honor yeah the next on
it so I'm sitting there and my wife's
she is a therapist and she's had a few
of her clients go to Iceland and come
back and say awesome it is so I'm
sitting there one night I'm supposed to
be able to tell you that she can tell me
that people like Iceland she doesn't
trust is there like you knows I'm Larry
got into a fight with Mickey whoa oh I
was like Larry get in here man thank you
good room oh so I so she so I'm sitting
I'm looking at them look at Instagram
Austin pops up a flight to Iceland and
the two hundred eighty bucks each
reasons like 700 yeah and so I just
yelling at my wife like hey you want to
go to I spent we can go over the kids
spring break she's like okay I'm like
all right boom and i buy three tickets
for was i was under thousand but yeah
crazy and then i'm sitting on him I
think Gareth would want to go to Iceland
he's a big he loves nature he lives
getting out there and seeing puffins and
seals and whatever so I just sent him a
text and he buy the ticket and that I'm
like we can find write this [ __ ] off we
can just do a blast and then I said it
he mailed my agent he's like I got you a
gig it's nope you're not gonna leave
with any money at all but we have a gig
it's what that's amazing that's all get
our tickets not really flying he said
there but for a week will do not yet we
got a huge fan base out there and I
don't even know hold on i know the
nordic language that was swahili dude i
mix it up I'm sure Tony language the
night before we get into your your news
stories here would you please feel free
to plug your podcast your social media
you're the network we're all on whatever
you'd like yeah yeah he uh ATC's our
network and I'm super excited about
what's happening on about you guys I am
it was a studio stuff and my podcast is
the dollop which is a history podcast in
which ivory story to Garrett Reynolds
and then he makes the funny and I watch
him and then and my Twitter's at Dave
Anthony but I'm very political on
Twitter so if you don't like that and
you know it's not not your thing exactly
why funny how wise I like the time you
are variable if I'm very political I'm
very environmentally sort of like it
minded kind of thing and then I wish I
was but honestly I'm just too ignorant
and I know it and I feel like I'll put
something out there that we even be
wrong or something to be like what about
this fluffy them again that's all right
someone cough I don't have the balls the
balance California does not break off in
the ocean premises now i'm waiting for
it to break off in that perfect puzzle
piece everyone thinks it's going to
breathe i love that people think it's
gonna break off of this exact shape when
they say everyone think it's going to be
and I don't think every one thing is
going ton of everyone there you go
people watch cartoons there you go with
political right there I would have said
everyone and then you would have jumped
on my ass I'm like and I'm done with the
political rant yeah yeah I would like it
to break up personally move away a
little bit big dough now would it be
great I mean dude I mean whatever I that
why you started the like a history based
podcast that you like not that politics
is tied to it I mean it is but like I
would you major in college well that's
the environmental stuff I majored in the
study of the year at this physical
geography so that we're at UC Santa
Barbara what's that yeah you have
churros are you from I I grew up in the
bay
area oh you are California yeah and
always I performed at UC Santa member
two weeks ago no you did it yeah they do
a weekly there they used to they did
when I was there yeah was it in the pub
no it's in like this little like theater
classroom you know those ones that are
like at a stage and everything is like
to back areas comedone I've done about
three or four shows there I'm not gonna
do a while but his mother [ __ ] it's
blast I love that campus I actually
wrote us I got this one script and like
you know the intro the beginning a movie
your meeting all the guys before they go
away in this trip yeah and the first
time you meet this one dad he walks
through the cap of the Sun is one of
like like he's like touring the school
and they potent was like you [ __ ] go
to school because my friend took me up
there she went there my friend Robin is
and she's like oh we were gonna go to
Santa Barbara like go wine tasting just
cruise around yeah let me show you the
campus and there was like a sorority uh
like field day like a vent and
everyone's in different colors and like
these shorts and socks I was like good
God he went to UC Santa Barbara and he
did it's every single year I would come
back to school and a good i forgot i
would say yes is it's like the only that
you got the great yeah and the town used
to have some great shows in the
surrounding area there too uh and my
favorite thing was always do it because
it was always great shows i never had a
bad show up there was always well
attended always a great audience yeah
and then you drive back the beautiful
PCH at night with the moon setting on
the Pacific Jay and I got pulled over on
the way back one night beatings no no no
I don't know why people you didn't know
why at first but man he was sure as [ __ ]
intent on having us go to [ __ ] jail
because he started leaving the a started
giving the cop [ __ ] oh and then the
Gothic cop walks back to the car and I
look at him ago what the [ __ ] are you
doing he's like what I thought that's
how you would handle this like why would
I [ __ ] that's why I act I've always just
kind of been like I want the reason why
I got pulled over before I'm doing
anything and that was the way I said he
goes I go what he pulled me over for and
he goes license registration like tell
me why you're pulling me over and he's
like I go I didn't do anything wrong and
he goes you got a tail like he got the
light hit me man tell you until he came
back yeah he was going to hit hair light
and he may be good I can smash it the 10
minutes [ __ ] yeah carolina
get out of here look at now you did let
us go you're high to let you go or maybe
a fixer to Gary just let you go no I
didn't say fixed shitty to fix that
attitude is what he said yeah yeah well
what happened was two female officers
had pulled up behind him visit movie I
see not and while they pulled us over
you start in you pull us over and 50
yards up here on the right is the
barracks so another one comes out and
they see these guys they pull behind and
I'm like what the [ __ ] happening but
it ended up I think these two ladies are
like let them [ __ ] going let's go
grab a bite to eat and whatever but I
wasn't Maya and they were like I get out
of here I don't know what I don't never
owe you I don't know how it works but I
imagine if they do write you up then
they have to do paperwork if he had it
at night so I get him a taillight and we
did I he calmed down I think those lady
said something was he calm down what he
actually said that I remember was
something like when you have a something
with the prius like if the right
headlight is out usually the left tail
light something about how they well your
blinker usually a clear back if any of
your tail lights are on your blinkers
out when you put your blinker on the
blinker inside will go really on most
cars it'll go faster you know I mean you
know your little bling ur like yeah when
it lights out it goes to let me know hey
you gotta [ __ ] light I had no idea I
didn't know it did that on purpose yeah
I uh decided I can't leave any get a
ticket he did not do it I get out of a
lot of tickets I've gotten a lot of
things just because I think I don't know
why I got one though oddly enough I
gotta think of a certain person I one
time this was really [ __ ] stupid back
when I was younger and I've told this a
long time ago but I had smoked to join I
was going to hang out in Hollywood and I
pull I'm i see this cop car stopped at a
light it's right on franklin as you can
make a right and go down Gower or
continuous great by the 101 cafe I'm
going east ok yeah and they're right
there at that light just as you come out
of the over the freeways above you and
they're there reverse lights are on and
I'm pulling up behind them and I see
that they reverse lights are on but I
notice it later so I abruptly jump ya
around them and I pull up next to them
both and it's summer my windows down and
both of them are just staring at me now
they're just Ariana hahaha so I start
motioning roll your window down and the
guys just icing me and I'm like we win
their now you're telling roll your
window down and he just looks at me goes
it is down I was like oh god yes
hilarious and I was like well your
reverse light sororities like what I go
I think you might have a short every
time you hit your brakes your reverse
lights also come on he just never takes
his glance off me goes we'll check it
back at the station I was like damn
right you were in the meantime get that
window up uh well I got I got pulled
over once and I was speeding through
Iowa which I mean manito the lives of
yet but I'm on one of those back roads
that are just two lanes and I'm flying
I'm doing like 85-90 and energy driving
a little rental car like a little how
can I can beat her and and I come you
know you come up one of those hills just
as a cop comes the other way and here's
you go boom I just I just stopped and
pulled off the road and waited for him
to turn around you really did yeah and
then he and then he just comes over he
walks something he goes that was
actually really good ideas like thank
you thanks a lot can you dig it well
then he then he had he had me get in his
car yes a [ __ ] new one that happened
to me in Texas so that's a thing like
its superintendent like what the [ __ ] is
going on here front seater back he had
me in the front driver side actually
front seat he put me in the drive real
test and he sat down and kept on what
are you gonna do he do nobody fix me and
he and then he and then he starts
talking to me and about what I'm doing
and went before my final year comedian i
thinkI again all something there and
then he was like alright so he goes you
can't do that here just I can you know
calm it down a little bit and drive the
speed limit and he let me go I love it
white privilege right not told that's
was a little white privilege boy
hilarious was he white yeah he was a toy
we definitely winked at each other
really yeah right
yeah I had the same thing the guy from
the other side of the from driving here
to California when I was moving out the
second time and the guy spots me from
across the freeway cuts through the
median like smoking the band [ __ ] how
fast I mean what i was going i think i
was going i can't remember if it was 70
miles an hour speed limit there or 75
whatever it was i was three miles an
hour over all that material said ok I
locked eyes with me lock die while
you're driving yeah and came right
through the median like smoking the
Bandit and [ __ ] pulled me over and
then made me get in this car and I I was
nervous too I was Levi was a playa what
do they do do they go through your car
is that when they call like the station
and run your plates they run on your
[ __ ] and they run it right with you
there yeah had me stand at the rear of
the vehicle first and say I did my
cruiser again I was like in it he's like
get in it and I sat down and I set up
front shotgun and I was like old the
joint you know what I go this is a
standard you know I've been I've never
had this happen to me and his immediate
question was how many times you've been
pulled over but i'm still shut the
[ __ ] videos only do for me in my hands
where my neck I mean a cop's life man
you know like all the stuff and there's
so much anti cops off in the last two
years which I totally get and i think is
totally justified but then if you watch
some of those videos where cops are
getting shot like when they just walk
over to a window for like I'll pull over
and a guy sticks a gun what I just
happening [ __ ] swear to God tonight
there's a car accident the cops pull up
to just think of mr. Clarkson one of the
guys start shooting out I mean kill kill
one and injured the other one the guy
and they even said they're like here two
cops are just thinking they're helping
someone our accident and they get shot
at the guy's got a warrant um yeah yeah
again any time now I see videos with
police where they're doing something
nice like there was one where a
girlfriend one it was getting engaged or
something like that and they all come
out and I'm like this could end really
badly like I'm thinking you're doing
this nice thing and people are so scared
these days that you could end up getting
[ __ ] shot just trying to you know
help somebody get engaged I don't know
it's not a job out to my cousin tired
yeah i mean i have a cop my family the
problem is is that most of them are good
but they're so [ __ ] bad ones and
there's a bunch of those a bunch of
those neo-nazis a long time ago and
their plan was to grow their hair out
and start drama joining law enforcement
so there's a bunch of [ __ ] racist now
yeah so it [ __ ] it up for everybody
yeah this is gonna be a bad seed just
like you're cool but you're racist right
right and we wanted to me and then what
the J being racist just want to make
video city that's not what happened some
people like that's not what happened no
I don't know why my cousin was out
visiting my my other cousin her brother
and we were over the house and the gas
tank was out of the grill was out of
propane and I'm like I'll go get
something he said I come with you I'm
like all right so we're cruising down
Ventura in the valley and I go you know
which you say it wasn't he's like okay
and I keep and I go there it is and I
monitor so I just banging Ewing like G
right were you doing yeah I know what it
is I'm a cop that's not illegal I cannot
work he just died and laughing cuz he's
like if you get pulled over and I'm in
here they're gonna freakin age my
cousins Got the Fraternal Order of
Police tags on his pickup you know so he
can get away with [ __ ] still even though
he's not very longer active and every
time we I go home and we go to a Ravens
game or Oriole game or go watch this
[ __ ] and he will pull up right in
traffic and they'll see his tag and I'll
just wave them right here shut up and
then we get a go wait what's happening
right now we're in an active lane that
they had they have shut down to direct
traffic and I see other cars there and I
go what's happening because that's where
they let you park if you're a cop and I
can walk out of here oh yeah and then
what we were going to shoot a couple
people and and your car sits out on the
[ __ ] Street in that close Lane parked
until the game's long over and you come
back every time so it's been a minute
since we had done it we go to ravens
game it's like two years ago we go to
ravens games Tim and me and
he goes up and he doesn't know this one
guy who just sees him he's like yeah I'm
with looking for you know whoever he
throws this guy's name out and a guy
knows he's [ __ ] right away and just
looks I'm good haven't been in the
department for two years haha but he
feels like you can park over there but
he do is try to get 10 frodo like nice
try dude that guy's butt out of this
[ __ ] Park the market park right up I
mean touching the brick they'll let you
park wherever the [ __ ] you want yeah I
totally get I you know I used to when I
first moved here I donated every year to
some law enforcement thing fund and they
send you a little [ __ ] window decal
that's nice so you can put on your car
and then the cosplayer and they know
you're a donator to this thing and I I
don't know why I stopped doing I think
might just not getting things from him
but I was always like this is kinda
interesting whatever will happen if I
get pulled over one year I did say this
is one of the strangest gigs ever did I
was the Cameron Bure what year was LAPD
robbery and homicide units Christmas
comedian holy SH out at a country club
during the middle of the day like now
and kids and [ __ ] are there and they're
telling me I can't cost I can't do a
[ __ ] but they all want to hear it of
course you know their dead bodies for a
living yeah you know there's an honor
where she's not upset them at all unless
I got him on the street go [ __ ] a little
and uh the mic was at an old wooden
podium and I mean it went about this far
so I had to stand still at a podium for
an hour you know Rises business means
and carrying them you know I was
carrying that thing around put it on
Wheels track but I did research on all
their open cases and I just started
calling them out no you did well RFK
still open technically no it isn't it is
well get that biggie smalls is really on
Kate went to jail I don't know that case
there handsome is officially I don't
know there's the guys in jail lock that
goes down it's still open on him
someone's just got to play I asked them
who zombie who's on to be a big EK said
they were like this guy they start
calling each other out of like who's on
RFK I didn't even know anything I knew
who shot here I didn't know was it okay
there's something still involved with it
where they haven't got somebody but you
right about that and there was a few
other ones i just kept calling them out
by department Wow but that's critical
question caller a tidy up I didn't know
what else today I what else do you do I
can't do those things when they say
don't cross him like a pie not the guy
you're looking for even a military tour
uh no I did one a USO thing in San Diego
but that was it yeah but I drew carey
asked me to go there you go say my
lasagna prices know he was like hey man
do i go to Fallujah I'm doing a gig
there and it was during the [ __ ] when
it was serious fighting and flew Joe's
like oh no I know I mean I want to tell
myself out as a [ __ ] but no I don't
want to go to all or so I am an absolute
supporter of our troops and everything
they do or are told to do but i am not
going over there to tell you guys
[ __ ] jokes I've done plenty of
military gigs here in California and out
on naval bases and things like that but
i'm not going to load I don't think I
would have done it I think I might have
done if i didn't have a kid because i
think my kid was just born or he were my
wife is pregnant one of the other like I
heard in their show but I might have
done it I did the heavy [ __ ] when I
didn't have kid and I round twice since
while I have kids but took guitar which
isn't right you know we're not even
technically there as long as you don't
like blow a guy on a beach you're fine
huh yeah and go to jail for that there
oh yeah I did like 30 well so I forgot
what I was going to say it was a really
good thing where were your talking man
it must have been the follow-up to the
blow and the guys on the beach blah blah
to be leaving that white wiping what I
was going to tell you if it's our Middle
East no never heard him never heard but
the World Cups going to be so that's
very excite now is it still going to be
there I know they were talking about the
temperatures could be like on the field
upwards of 100 oh yeah 33 the time on
air conditioned thing and but the funny
thing is the stadium's they they make
the men and women and their four
different side so they really yeah they
held like a club world championship
there or something and nobody knew
people came from other countries and
they're like what do you mean I got it
so people are getting split like you
come with your wife and all soon you
guys going to sit somewhere else like
people are [ __ ] flip and I
oh you can't even sit together either no
well you gotta cuz I'm all for us
entering on different times yeah our
lines going way quicker than that
[ __ ] bag check they got over there
I'm down for that I'll meet you to see
the top for that you won't hear a good
cop story yeah alright so I lived in
Brooklyn aqwal years just 90 well part i
lived in Park Slope I lived there too oh
you did fifth in lincoln place holy [ __ ]
i lived on fifth and carol right by the
the key supermarket oh yeah yeah it was
like a weird street like it was the only
what it didn't go through because the
supermarket was there I know and then
there was a big brick wall what year
this is like I lived there from like 95
297 okay how was their way later yeah
but when I would there was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was the shizzle yeah it
improved rapidly but it was like Carolyn
and you know that kind of thing Elliott
Smith look around the corner I don't
know if you know who he is boo Hayley
Smith musician oh yeah joyed heroin and
died of it did you know I know you know
he could have himself oh that's right
well and his girlfriend kill them so
either one oh you know staggers off
twice in the [ __ ] heart you're
passionate I'm used to do his music it's
kind of committed so it was like a kind
of a weird little neighborhood and so
that street was blocked off and there
was a big sidewalk where this lady
always had a dog [ __ ] and she never
cleaned it up so it was like I just was
like a sidewalk just cover [ __ ] Oh any
of you confronted good can you pick a
plaque she liked my house is not going
well what is it dog it treated like yeah
although like a king I was gonna say
probably the only thing she did let's do
whatever it wants yeah i mean he's
[ __ ] ruling everything he's just he
probably shits in the house and she's
like all right yeah so uh so I come home
after a gig it's like midnight and I
walk down the street and I opened up our
gate so there's like a 10 foot walk to
the hat from the gate to the house and I
just open up I look and there's a pistol
just if I can revolver sitting in your
walkway yeah just just sitting on the
walkway uh-huh it's America man
there they comment what did you do well
that just yet i was like what do i do
something that's a weird thing and then
stop let's pick it up start shooting
shooting into the neighbors houses do
you watch so i will say that i mean the
thing about a gun to me like why I don't
have one is because if you hold one yeah
you can shoot it if you know what I mean
and I don't say I don't think I have
vertigo in life but like that would be
my example of it like like it's here
here like you're really that much more
apt to shoot something when you can
actually have it totally it's instant
power and I'm much less angry than I was
but if I had a gun back in the day as
there'd be some holes in people we're
[ __ ] sure so I'm like what do I do
you can't leave it here right like I
said some what a kid finds right yeah
and like now I don't know maybe or a dog
the dog could find it so I pick it up
and I can I live in a three story you
know what kind of pistol it is it looks
like a 38 special kind of [ __ ] gun
it's like oh like a will hold up done
yeah like a like it's a salami I'm
thinking someone commits a crime not
like a desert eagle [ __ ] hang on oh
it's got letters and so so I I'm
thinking that someone commits a crime
and then drove by and through it right
so um so I walk I walk up to three
stores and I walk into my room it was a
guy who just watched TV these when I
walk in just over the pistol and he's
like what the [ __ ] you do yeah I was
like get on the floor how you did y'all
get oh my god could you fall for it but
then I was like in the tournament what
do we do I mean do week wasn't loaded
yeah it's [ __ ] loaded it's ready to go
and you touching it with your hand are
you covering with no no I didn't even
think about that I check it out when I
bring it into a house and that well
that's all if I'm sitting there I'm like
so what do we do do I mean I don't
really want a gun I'm probably not the
guy should have a gun he's like no you
definitely should not have a gun and so
I was like well I guess you call the
police yeah I mean who else do you call
it I wouldn't be called a definite first
call but it's also like there's also got
to be some sort of fear that they're
gonna be like oh really really
found that we just cause well trace it
to her murder yeah she goes down we go
to the hole in his head I gotta battle
his right hand hey I found a gun it just
shot a guy in the face so so I call that
I call the police department the local
number and and the disk written woman
the answers and she's just super bummed
she's like okay like just not into [ __ ]
it sounds like it's something that
happens a lot yeah and she's like okay
we'll send someone over and my god this
is [ __ ] weird and so I sit there by
the window and do just holding it I'm
just Ola I'm totally playing it like a
loaded gun we just pop off once like God
like I at this point I've had no
experience with guns if you guys ever
shot a gun yes you have you haven't you
have yeah I took like a training course
and where I listen to a guy from the NRA
tell me how much of [ __ ] liberals are
and I'm like um that's me I just don't
have to go yeah as an MC to team Giada
ak-47 up in the military though yeah
right yeah I'm hoping that no neighbor
in Iraq like one day they're like oh go
to the shooting range and then they take
out you sit on the top of a Humvee with
a 50 Cal that you put your thumbs in the
little pedal yeah they shoot out like
the size of this water bottle and
they're just with flames coming out the
back and then we shot like all yet we
got this on phone Russians Williams an
ak-47 like I want to shoot Disney like
yeah and then 50 50 m 16 all that [ __ ]
oh my see that sounds I would like to do
that it was pretty crazy yeah right one
I would too yes I actually went kid was
on top of the 50 the Humvee and we're
all like taking pictures and he's like
I'll get a pic and he turns us and as he
does his hands drop down and it started
shooting over the burn you know like the
sand wall were shooting it do like
anything could have been there anybody
could have been on that other kids in
Detroit oh well that mean we had an old
neighbor that had a it was pretty clear
a tommy gun an old original timeline of
those yeah yeah you know you funky love
lounge yeah there's that thing was
badass and he had just a big open yard
in the back he could you could get you
still can get ammo that recently
no how the [ __ ] he did it I don't know
who I don't you know what I always do
not ask yeah it's not a question hey we
give me I'm just like this is pretty
tight it was it was a pretty badass
little tommy gun it was cool to shoot
one of those things yeah I'd like to see
one of those I might might I really
really really want to shoot an AK you
know you see the videos of the women and
yeah I want I totally want to get in a
speedo and have a video of me shoot yeah
right yeah yeah I can see it's one of my
go for guys like yeah I I had a friend
of mine who had an ak-47 at his house
and I'm just like first of all he should
not be a person that should be allowed
to get an a cave or you feel like that
works is a lot of people say all people
should not be 11 ak-47 that to be
militaria but he had one he's like let's
go out back and it's two o'clock in the
morning we're sober one hundred percent
over and I'm like he's like just shoot
it down into the ground I'm like what he
said he shows me the bull I couldn't
believe the size of the bullets like
things I shoot it down on the ground and
I'm like this this is I mean it's super
rural but it's still a neighborhood you
know I shoot this [ __ ] thing in on
the ground because I'm not passing up on
that I'm up on the deck and I shoot it
in the ground it it sounded like it
rained for two minutes of shirt just
float flying in the air and then coming
down through the trees and I was like
holy [ __ ] he's like I gotta go down
there and get the case and you got are
looking for so that it because neighbors
have called before reporte cuz there's a
war going on next door oh my god and
then like a [ __ ] so this is how dumb I
am he he had it unloaded obviously in
the kitchen sitting up on a little stand
on the table when i get behind it i'm
like take a picture be just behind this
thing and i take that in the summer
months and months and months but i don't
ever do anything with the picture one
morning I remember Jay over tell you
this is some such an idiot one morning I
get up I [ __ ] without looking at the
news or anything I just tweet the
picture I'm about to redecorate the [ __ ]
out of this kid zone know and people hit
me up and go hey should check the news
Colorado movie shooting oh my god and I
immediately take it down how but how
great would that was a picture view of
the Joker's that would have been the
work you know at that time too I had so
few fault I still don't have a lot of
Twitter followers but so few i just
threw an apology out like one and then
that was it for me I come a little bit
like what a [ __ ] arrow oh it always
made me laugh when i'm on twitter and
something bad is happening and a friend
of mine's like hey man i'll be in reno
just like Jared 30 people dead and he's
like yeah I got a great president like
just not paying attention at all yeah so
I so what happened so I'm standing by
the window pop car pulls up I'm like all
right but I go across the room to buzz
him in and and then I wait if I can take
out a long time but was caught to get up
the stairs and then he knocks on the
door I open it up and there's an old
it's an old guy he's like he's like 55
black black guy street clothes he's not
a uniform it's not what I'm expecting at
all he's bearded gray beard and he's
like hey man is you found my gun he
shit-faced out of it really holy [ __ ] he
said I heard you found my gun heard you
found my gun and I'm like yeah yeah and
uh and and they still our am I uh am i
racist like this doesn't feel this feels
weird I mean I was really great why give
it to the guy but he's he's yes so what
do i do right like Anna there and I've
got the gun in my hand I'm like I kind
of don't want to give a drunk guy a gun
because he's also not just I expected a
uniformed cop it was definitely a cop
car deftly cop car plain clothes car one
hundred percent of cop cars if this is a
coen brothers movie he takes the gun he
shoots you that's right that's right you
know so there's a there's a moment where
I'm like ah I think I said like so I
just give this to you and then he pulls
us this jacket assigned he's got his
badge
and I'm like look okay and I hand him
the gun he already has another gun in a
holster so so this is a gun that he
liked tucks in his pants me and I'm like
this is weird and that Anthony goes what
are you drinking I'm like uh yeah I'm
good and he's what you drink man and I'm
like you you like Jack Daniels and I'm
like I don't really drink hard alcohol
and you [ __ ] [ __ ] no god I'm getting
[ __ ] it's like my dad's here yeah oh my
god oh [ __ ] drinking you drank too
much so he goes so he goes were you you
don't drink it all on my like beer man
I'm long he's all right I just leaves
that was it that was it it's a plant gun
I do think was his blanket and I think
he was taking a piss in our yard and it
[ __ ] dropped out you think it was
really his I really think it was his
yeah so he leaves and I'm like well that
was weird yeah about so I'm watching TV
and I'm sitting in my chair where you
can just look out the window did you
think you would get some kind of like
metal do you think you're gonna get
something right I didn't know like I
thought I thought I thought they'd be
like hey man this is great you're
awesome I didn't expect to be this
[ __ ] weird experience around like I
might get capped so sitting there about
you probably ended up coincidentally
calling the chick he dates on the floor
she's like all right that's right sounds
like that like I gotta call gerald up
until listen man they found your gun all
right all right I'm drink and I'll go
over and get it what is only one we
don't know what that s the second how is
that your phone no that's not myself
that I the water % a sword a watch or
yes I landed so anyway an alarm saying
don't give a get your gun so so so half
half hour later I'm sitting there that I
can see out the cop car pulls up same
car same car kind of like [ __ ] so now
I'm like this is some thought whatever
is happening is [ __ ] but now I'm like
I'm getting arrested because something
happen with that [ __ ] gun fingerprint
yeah but [ __ ] look down
he two cops get out on either side and
then he gets out the back and they walk
around to the trunk and they popped the
trunk and the check out of case of
heineken yeah Oh Ali optically said I
put on [ __ ] Kevlar vests and then
they put on the Kevlar thank you again
they took a shotgun and then they [ __ ]
bring me in case of beer amazing he
asked her what's he like he did ask me
what I lie and they didn't let him drive
he was too wasted we're at it right and
that pussy's up the rehearsal he's in
the women look and he'd come back he had
[ __ ] him got shit-faced she took a
piss in my yard he dropped his gun and
then he realized he got home he realized
he dropped his gun and he called up the
station he's like this is drunken Lou I
ja I gonna yeah and then they just they
took Jace Meredith wake man but anyway
what you will that's a great actually
but it was so clearly a drop gun it was
not a gun that a cop has it's definitely
not a standard it was like it was like a
level playing in 38 special yeah it was
his plan no what do we have here go now
my fingerprints were yeah yeah yeah so
for a while after that I was like that
[ __ ] going to shoot some one of them
hey you you are take the fall that gun
is still in a plastic bag somewhere in
an evidence room were not done that's
not your Darren either right here's an
island continues buddy my my buddy
Shannon nu J met when we actually were
on tour back in Baltimore as a junkyard
in this shady little section of the city
and on his way to work just not long
before we got there he is driving and
there's a gun in the middle of the road
and he stops and picks it up in calls
and it was it was a gun used in a
robbery or see that is right totally was
and they just dumped it right there on
the street he was like that's a [ __ ]
gun like his point was any kid could
grab by just let me grab it same thing
called the police they came out but it
was a weapon they were looking for yeah
but then of course they come in question
you r at first but he found the guy for
what the [ __ ] you know where were you
right yeah exactly i was just over
driver you mean the gut rock I mean
yep well but that's true cuz kids pick
up guns and because they've seen what
happens when they shoot them because
they don't know that there's a serious
repercussions at all yeah I mean I tell
my kid killed my grandfather that's how
I did it yeah it's a mercy you lied it
might have been you know I might have
set it up but baby over you [ __ ] what
do you Saddam Hussein well you you were
telling us you've been robbed before
yeah i've i've been robbed at gunpoint
I've been robbed two times at gunpoint
at once without a gun she's she'd been
robbed three times one time I was in
high school and I might it might have
been involved in drugs what do you mean
selling I yeah I manage so where'd you
in high school Marin County Marin County
so we were all doing [ __ ] drug it was
like the one time we were all on
mushrooms in the middle that it was like
a wednesday or some [ __ ] we all did
mushrooms and then the news was on
because that's what you do when you're
on mushrooms and dan Rather came on us
and later we will go to bring County the
teenage drug capital of the world we're
all like [ __ ] yeah yeah so I used to go
I used to buy coke but mostly mushrooms
but sometimes i buy coke and or pot at
but I had a mushroom connection but to
get coke or pot I had to get it in two
different the different or people I
didn't know right so there's a place
called the docks when I went down there
no they're well but docks and already my
authority may i'm already that's the
school spelling i'll be back here wait
the next cop by a case we just go me
he's a good guy sex i got out of the
docs and is it actually the doc yeah
it's a dachshund any high school college
I'll be overly high school I'm like 16
17 and and I have a big wad of cash you
know I'm going to buy some coke and I'm
gonna go sell it to my friends I'm not
going to sell it to people i don't know
alleged yeah just kill the people you
love right so so i pull up and and it's
it's just like you [ __ ] see on all
the shows where they're like the white
kids come down and they get away with
this and
a black guy doesn't it's totally what it
is like it's just where white people go
to buy jugs from from these guys so I
pull up there's a couple of a couple of
dudes there and and they're like what do
you want now these black guys or white
god guys I got a bigger what do you want
I go on eight ball no i think is it too
there's a lot of money are you solo Oh
what hey by yourself but yeah you're
absolutely I don't know your body smart
we're all alone in this situation but
you remember what it do you remember
what an eight ball cost then like how
much money are you are is on you well
they might think it cost eight hundred
dollars so you got six nine hundred
million dollars and find to a pause
because I want my friend that one for me
yo [ __ ] yeah but we were rolling in cash
it was crazy does that drug trade cuz of
the drug trade so so I roll up and I go
on to eight balls in his alright you got
the money and I go yeah and he goes I
let me see and I take he just takes it
and he goes alright thanks man and I'm
like what he goes yeah we're done oh man
and I'm like really and he just shows me
a gun I go okay seen one of those I'm
gonna take off snap of the extent of the
deal really yeah it is wrong just right
up here because I'm a [ __ ] set of
sure he was sixteen dollars in cash my
prom money man I'll tell you what the
only guy I wanna call with the guy whose
gun you found got to be the only yeah
you can trust like listen I know I'm not
supposed that of a my god so that's like
a my semi robbery story that like that's
definitely a robbery idiot story of any
well [ __ ] a lesson learned yeah lesson
[ __ ] it's more money can i come back
anyway you want 38 balls like diamonds
so uh we're done so the second time I
saw now I'm doing stand-up in the city
open mics and [ __ ] so I got a part-time
job as a bank teller San Francisco so
I'm doing it in doing comedy time just
go but I'm living in marin in this town
of san rafael and I know Sam her phone
you did yeah my buddy lives in lagunitas
all right yeah and and so I'm there one
day and this lady walks up
work she's like four foot to a little
tiny baby and she hands me a note and
says give me all your money and I was
like oh no it didn't accumulate to give
me a hundred dollars and i was like he
do that I was like man it's awesome I
remember looking at housing one and she
could just get me a hundred not me a
hundred dollars and it's a have a good
nose I have a gun give me hundred off so
I look at the note and I'm like wait I
subscribed the lady do you remember what
she looks like 42 she is she like a
little tiny thing or a little time'
dating no she's not intimidating at all
she looks like she doesn't get out a lot
beating me yeah no she's not your
penmanship look great right great right
great it wasn't like cut out of
magazines she just got like a short
short haircut she's wearing like a Down
Jacket kind of thing Brown and she stand
she's just very sort of nondescript kind
of frumpy kind of you know it's the kind
of person you wouldn't really look at
you know and I go are you sure that's
what what you want because it's clearly
something's [ __ ] weird here right and
she goes yeah and I go you don't want
any more you offer more not much I'm
willing but I'm leading up to the next
robbery so she goes no and I'm I take a
hundred other bill out my slide a Custer
and cheese this is a protest and I'm
like what and she goes I was just out of
meeting with hm they are treating women
so horribly in this country and I'm like
oh are you sure so you don't want the
money I was like are you sure you want
to do this and she goes yes and she
takes it and she goes call the police oh
my [ __ ] she just goes on sits up front
on the steps waiting for my show and
then we call the [ __ ] cops and they
call it a rest gently it's just a bad
idea so that's what the [ __ ] right yeah
it's mental health so that's yeah so
that's robbery number one but did it
leave the Hundred she they just took her
away I love that you were like all right
I don't want more
I robberies work right I could have just
not given it to it a bit like this will
be better trust me so so then a couple
months later same Bank same Bank this
dude comes in and he is [ __ ]
squirrelly looking he's definitely a
drug addict he's got a big military
jacket on uh super unshaven but in a
terrible way I'm already here yeah super
thin older 40 maybe and he's just like
sweating and and so I'm sitting there
and there's three tellers my god help
the other ones get him let's give him
trying to go slow but they're clearly
doing the same thing and then he walks
up and he puts a gun down damn yeah what
he had it in his pocket and he goes this
is a robbery and then he puts it down
like five does he hold it or did you
leave it he'd guys he's got his hand on
and it's like sitting on the counter and
so you can't really see because they're
like these little window things so
people to the side can't see you know is
the gun so is there like a little dip or
underneath none of that it's just a
[ __ ] counter at this this is when ma
got it there's a place on in santa
monica on main street santa monica
banker well it's like a private bank
kind of a smaller Bank yeah and they
don't have anything up and they used to
get robbed [ __ ] awesome right yeah
yeah well this is back then they didn't
they didn't do this at all there weren't
now you go in and there's just [ __ ]
crazy you know glass up and you gotta
slide a thing through and all that [ __ ]
but I still think a lot of places they
don't have that the la's LA was like the
bank robbery capital the world for a
while so when I first moved back here
the second time was that crazy bank of
america shootout yeah good god north
wall you know the best thing is we did a
dollop on that did you really that thing
is [ __ ] crazy I mean they remember
seeing that on live TV the bullet go
through the do shot two dude I'm like
good God later they replayed it they cut
that away but you saw it when they
[ __ ] pulled those guys over near my
house and glendale like a year before
that really on a traffic stop and pop
the trunk and it's just full of guns
like they were about to go do it then
and they went to jail for like 90 days
or that's it yeah
and then they got onto that he met the
driver in jail I was that was a scary
day yeah it was [ __ ] up so uh so he he
just give me your money and now the
waywards of bank tellers you have a cash
drawer and then but underneath you have
a little like more a little thing you
lock and open up and bang keep it locked
your own personal bank and and between
the two year only supposed to have ten
at the time $10,000 max and if you get
over ten thousand dollars you go to the
head back to where you go hey I'm gonna
you know turn some cash and so lock bank
is to restock the shorter bank and then
don't know you have there yeah well in
case someone comes in with drawers like
six thousand dollars you have it but
also yeah the restock it if you're
running low I'd like 22 seconds before
he gets in your line like I'm over 10
grand I'm holding a king come on sir
love your jacket so I and so you just
have 15 up here and then you know so I
am a very lazy bank teller and I'm
rolling with like 15 16 thousand dollars
and I just don't give a [ __ ] is ok I
have more questions there's no button
under each individual to a silent alarm
to hit this room under each person thing
or yeah you're like you have a little
button render needs to activate just hit
it and then you're also supposed to give
cash marked or something that is marked
so there's you have you have a I think
it's four twenty-dollar bills do they
walk you through this training oh yeah
you don't do the die in a bag or
anything i don't know we had that we
didn't have dying about but i think they
have died in a bag if they go to the
safe the vault into the hall because
because this is like a little robbery
that they don't really give a [ __ ] about
like keep the money that they can trace
but that's about it so i take the money
out of the drawer and i go i go here i
put it down and six pretty his pockets
and i go i give you want more with you
wifeys as he's like the horse top seller
sighs you business a lot more won't show
any money I don't give a [ __ ] would be a
great stall tactic had you press the
button yet I had press the button okay
it's a good stall tactic well so so then
I he go he looks like totally confused
and I am unlock the thing and now i'm
just taking a big bundles of cash and
put them does anyone else knows what's
going on no no one there's a manager hi
may not pay attention to tell us and he
decided you're not paying attention at
all to this clear clear drug at a guy
like the guys out of his mind and so I'm
putting down big cash and a zine with
the gun back at this point with the cash
yeah yeah he's put the Gunners pot with
cash and he's just [ __ ] bug eyes just
like always it's right here good but
better than I right and then I said do
you need a bag it's a lot of money he
just have pockets how am I gonna be ten
cents but would you like it back how
much have you given him at this point
even though I gave him I gave him over
fifteen thousand dollars Jesus Christ
daddy I'm mobile to get under [ __ ]
lady down the street so I can come in
and get a hunter have to be Valdemar I
told you I told you'd ask if you wanted
more sir so I give it all to him and Ike
if I came a bag yeah you know no think I
run out with cash flying yeah you know
it's unprofessional yes thank you and he
puts it he puts it on his bag I'm super
just like I'm totally like I'm not
freaked out I'm just totally relaxed
about this and then he and then he takes
off and I turn around I'm like hey I
just got robbed hey i just i was going
to complet the manager laughs cuz im so
casual about it yeah and she goes hahaha
and I'm like no seriously I just got
robbed shoes what are you talking about
like that guy just help me up he and she
goes how much did you get ago he got
everything he took it all forcefully I
mean the only wanna think
god I said [ __ ] it and she goes what do
you mean everything I go I gave him that
I gave him all of it and she's like did
he ask for it i was like no but she's
like what the [ __ ] is happening as like
I just gave him and all I was fine with
it I'm ago and now they call the they
call the cops FBI everyone's [ __ ]
there in two minutes feel like did you
hit the button like I hit the button
they go over the camera the camera
didn't run and though it didn't hit the
button I'm like I hit the [ __ ] button
kids at the camera doesn't work so they
didn't get the guy on film at all Rick
did you hit the button I totally hit the
bot you did it i 100% at the button and
no because they tried it afterwards and
it wasn't working so now so now this is
Marin and what does the button do just
silent alarm direct island or well it
turns on the cameras at the same time so
in fact why don't they just have him
running all the time why think now they
do they turn to you they turn what do
you mean like Aaron cameras there I know
at this point a man I didn't hit the bus
it's a big shout out there the cameras I
could direct like a good i didn't hit it
man i don't want this guy came from so
now so this is maroon so if you don't
know Moran brain is like the widest
place on earth like you can't get a
wider richer place isn't that where
what's the new HBO series pretty little
big little eyes a little i think it is
better it's more like a very white in
affluent yeah yeah yeah yeah affluent
yeah how do you say affluent whatever he
seated right away that it wasn't sense
are you say yes I I thought a fake so
across so if you drive across the
richmond bridge now you have richmond
which is a tough place to live specially
east richmond a lot of [ __ ] gangs one
of the highest murder places and it's
like so it's it's crazy that those two
places are just separated from a bridge
so I tell them what happened the guy was
black who robbed me and then the girl
next to me who is a
Mormon from Marin could not be more
secluded or isolated her whole life
because I saw him and I'm like you
didn't see him and she goes I didn't she
gives a description and I'm like and
then the cops go we got him and I'm like
oh really and they go yeah he's in he's
in Richmond I'm like what so is that
possible cuz he get to Richmond that
quick they could because we're right
next to the highway but [ __ ] man it's
pretty it's a stretch yeah that he and
so they're driving us out there they
want us to ID him on the street oh man
and so I'm driving there and I'm like
your dad is a game I 16 we call you 16
now are you going down the back of his
cars my window Kambli on give a narrow
tie on name that terrible and and they
pull up and it's on it's on the [ __ ]
highway it's on the side of the highway
in richmond and there's a dude who is
one hundred percent not the guy who
robbed me so he's like a 50 year old
black dude who's just probably going
home from work and the [ __ ] care in
this guy's eyes because he knows what's
happening he knows that too [ __ ]
white [ __ ] from bryn are coming over
to potentially ID him and how many dudes
get a jail the situation [ __ ] 95
right so I look in his eyes I'm like
this guy I go I oh that's not him and
she goes that's him and I go that's not
[ __ ] him and she's like that's him
really yeah and I and I looked at her
and I go think about what the [ __ ] are
you doing right now I could did you get
robbed I got robbed were you looking at
him for [ __ ] three men did you give
more money than he wanted I did you
probably was taking a gun on hand I
didn't could you ask me we wanted the
rest of the money no I did that and she
finally shuts up and I go I look at the
content of that is not him 10 percent
that's not the guy and the cops were so
it's
in you they want they were so yeah they
wanted they wanted to stay though they
were so disappointed in me because they
wanted me to say that was if ever I and
then they just quietly goes back over
totally bummed to do got away with it ok
so if like five months later they caught
him cuz he kept robbing banks because
why wouldn't you right because to hear
me to make change now he's probably
going and going get in the [ __ ] safe
yeah I want more last guy asked for one
I have rods on ebay three times a night
and your your personal services not you
should work on this you should really
work on so they only got him because he
got greedy not because the traceable
money that's right he nothing it was
nothing to do with our robbery but he
kept hitting up other banks ham now my
manager goes to a what convention or
whatever like a meeting of all the
managers in the state and when she walks
in they all break into applause and they
given award because I broken the record
for giving away money by a bank teller
in califor the comp seller for giveaway
giveaway that guy hit the jackpot on
your nose and not by like a little bit
like a [ __ ] oh my god that's an
actual ward they give out no me because
well yeah yeah listen we got to add both
robberies to be in all fairness from the
same bank so how much did you give away
total 16 plus you got to take it all as
a hundo god I'm gonna wait wasn't there
another time no those was at first the
first time was the first time I got
robbed oh yeah oh yeah and they're a
clown and her and giving her award yeah
you give did she show you the award yeah
looks like a little you don't have a
photo of that I don't know god damn i
wish you have that note lady if you
write but you got to give that you got
to give that set off since it is but
that yeah I can still picture it in my
mind that ya know well that exact thing
happened to me in college and I'm not
kidding you when I tell you I had under
probably under five hundred dollars in
this bag
account I went into the bank back when
you would fill out a slip oh yeah you
know the little buck slip or whatever
and I took one off the top and filled it
out and I'm waiting in line 34 people
had a member there for a few minutes and
I remember handing the slip too late and
it as I did and she took it I saw that
there was something scribbled on the
back and my immediate thought was it was
asking her on a date or hittin on her or
something sexy inappropriate that's what
I don't know why you think that that's
the greatest I don't know what happens
right I this is probably me just by me
asking this lady's like my day that's
really the kind of [ __ ] I thought could
have been written on the back of it and
she was not an attractive older lady at
all so immediately I'm like oh and she
just freezes and never once in my mind
do I even think that it could be
anything like write a bank robbery at
all yeah and she just goes ghost white
I'm look and that now in hindsight I
start saying what's it say and I can see
now that it probably sounds a little
cocky and arrogant oh right so years
because of wandering message what we're
back yes lady yeah really yeah David be
like don't worry woman I got it ya llego
she shows it to the lady next to her the
texture and that woman screams and
immediately puts her hand over her mouth
to stop the screen and that's when I
realized these people are not good at
her job this shit's not good yeah and
I'm how old are you top 20 well not even
I'm 19 yeah yeah 19 and I'm like what's
its now I get super nervous on ya what's
it say and she turns it around it says
this is a holdup give me all your money
and I'm like oh I just want I was just
here for thirty bucks I was I was there
for like fifty bucks to go out for the
[ __ ] weekend I don't even have a lot
of money in there and I'm like and I
start arguing I'm like what you have all
of my information my face is uncovered
I'm on camera well you know who the [ __ ]
robs a bank like this
yeah i gotta go i might do this i have
no weapons and they [ __ ] detain me
and they make me talk to the security
for a while and I'm like look that's
probably some [ __ ] Punk waiting in
line with his mom board rotor on stuck
in and I'm the Jackass lotto ticket that
took that one next and went up there and
I was scared to death we're gonna have
an old is a lot I'm doing it today
destroy I'm gonna go in the back god
damn man that's scary yeah you weren't
but none of them had their face covered
or anything huh no they just cruise in
because you really can't because you're
if you're if you're in line in a bank
you have anything covering your face on
you can't you can't come approach the
tellers go get the [ __ ] back you can
because every guys would have their
motorcycle helmet right like no dude you
can't walk up the motorcycle pelvis I
don't want to worry about this I never
take it off for your you really want to
see this at all the winter with a face
mask good see like now hang it up just a
guy in a pig mask what I'm just taking
out money um I wish that guy that had
robbed you using hey you want my watch
man I gotta watch you think these shoes
every nice shoes good for you did right
now who gives a [ __ ] it's not my money
it's not your money it's ensure who
cares yeah who gives us a goal in that
situation is to get out alive right
that's exactly right even if it was my
money I'd like take it and the more the
more money given the less chance he's
going to shoot you right right yeah you
give more money's got to take his hands
and tie it up and that's when where's
the shitty security at that [ __ ] bank
should have been on in fact no security
there was a there was a you really had
knows another DVR security back knows
the [ __ ] zero you just and it was
right next to the highway so you could
just roll in take it and run out the
door and you know clearly in a minute at
the most I think they closed down that
Bank well because of the location yeah I
was gonna say that's the bank to hit
right yeah [ __ ] yeah or the amount of
money we should might have to put it up
a we should will link to it so if
anybody wants to rob it yeah yeah we can
link to it is it robbed the fat guy
goodness how much time do we have
because I you got to go no I was gonna
say yes i can tell you another letter
here crime story let's hear another
crime story so i was i was engaged to I
moved out here with a woman I was
engaged to you from New York wasn't good
with money so when you stay out here is
it because you went to New York I went
yeah i live in new york for for almost
five years met her was like you know
let's i guess we'll get married it was
literally one of those okay all right
and and we drive out here together and
so we're living together don't worry I
know where we get some money for the
wedding so she's weird with money yeah
like she has you been so normal I never
hears not like it's genius like me yeah
but she would be she was like have no
money and she would still buy [ __ ] and
I'd be like don't me not buy stuff when
you like she's running up her credit
cards and and and one day I gotta
commercials like a Lexus commercial and
she looked at me because can I quit my
job and my foot why what's happening
like know some guy heard about the
course on I gave him the money I'm not
getting elected so uh so one day I get
up in the morning and she's bawling just
[ __ ] flying anyway what's going on
talk to me and she goes that was the
that was the mob on the phone I'm like
what usually you sit down if I can tuck
calm down talk to me she goes my dad is
gambler time Mike oh and Amelia I was a
hugger hunting start to make sense like
she doesn't know how to handle money I
could just start all sort of clicking
and she goes she feels really bad that
he couldn't pay for a wedding because
he's the you know bride's father okay
and she goes so he went so he lives in
the will ferrell is gonna portray him
up what's the [ __ ] part of brooklyn
cobble cobble hill cobble hill so
there's in colorado and that that used
to be old school mom okay and so he
still can he grip this he's still
connected with all these guys so he goes
and borrows I think he's not called
borrow nothing bombarded the whole idea
he asked for a five-thousand-dollar loan
because he has such shitty credit that
he can't go to a regular bank or do it
doing he really wants to three years of
bender yea high Valyrian 5k my MOT what
do you have any idea what the point are
on that it's [ __ ] her like forty
percent yeah it's more than that it's
[ __ ] crazy good sale no gonna have to
rama they all known him and they know
who he's just a [ __ ] guy who [ __ ] I
but Fred they know him as the gambler so
they if they give him money they're
gonna huge points so it might not even
started five grand might have been 2500
and then had now turned into five grand
at this point so trying to go all out
for that wedding huh wow this is what he
does so he wants to throw a big wedding
right 5000 so you go he goes too hot
there I'll take that money of the track
right he's gonna turn he's going to turn
that whatever it is 2500 we just started
5,000 in a week he's going to turn that
into like fifty thousand dollars for a
[ __ ] win in advance this is a plan
gentlemen the guy's got a plan he's
thinking ahead yeah so he loses it all
and he also doesn't have the kind of job
where he's like a salesman and at this
point he's a phone salesman where people
call in and order office supplies so
that's a job that's going away pretty
quick with the internet and everything
else so he he now owes them five grand
they want more they want a payment plan
and he doesn't have it and so they call
him a very nice to them they even offer
a payment plan usually the payment plan
is we want our money right now we want
to right that's the plan so these guys
are out of Long Island the guys who
fronted the money right
it wasn't the guys in Cobble Hill that
was his connection and they want him to
get on a train and go out to Long Island
and they're going to break his legs i
will pick you up and understand but Liz
if you could take train back hope that
you're gonna need yeah who would ever
get all your errands done on foot before
you get here because this go be a mother
[ __ ] I never take the three third again
you get hour later in 330 it's backed up
and then there's guys at the station
just getting a number too so so he's
obviously freaked out and my fiance is
totally freaked out and I'm like okay
what do I gotta do to make this go away
so the guy who had called this mob guy
given her his own over and so I call it
oh my god and I'm like hey and he goes
who is this I'm like I am the fiance
future son-in-law of Barry and he's like
yeah so what do you what do you want to
do about this I was like I I will pay it
yes so you are gonna take over this loan
kind of like and I'm telling casual oh
nice round her like I'm like yeah yeah
I'm gonna take it over he goes you
understand that you were going to take
over this loan and I'm like yeah I'm
starting a little nervous and he goes I
want you to say it in those words and
I'm like a born you have not asked legit
what the actual debt is yeah i know it's
5,000 so you're taking his word for it
though yeah I am okay let these guys see
me you don't ya any of those willing to
give a little more the guy gave it
opportunity to go away it's like how
much we met regularly Opie I might even
seven I give you ten trust me I got a
reputation so do you want more so you
guys uh
saying they all okay I'm I'm gonna take
over the loan and he goes the loan is
now yours which Jesus Christ here's what
you're gonna do you're gonna go to the
bank you guys are going to look at this
guy named Dave he's going to give you
this whole drawer yeah in a wire the
money to this account that's my wife's
account and and then we will be done so
I Drive to the bank and they wire the
mob $5,000 Christ and and then I cone up
and he goes our business is finished you
should keep an eye on your future father
and okay I feel like that's like that to
think that's the takeaway that's yes yes
the real long time so then I go back and
then she might sensitive reveals that
she like grew up hiding her money in her
like the family's money or sock drawer
dad would come in at night dig through
the drawers and take it and gamble it
and the whole rest of his family I never
knew I the rest of the family he was the
black no would talk to him anymore it's
really gambled everyone's money away and
I was like holy [ __ ] and then I and then
it did and that was like the end of our
relationship because I knew that she
would never understand money or how
[ __ ] work no and I was like oh this
is a bad anyway the great part of the
story is when we got engaged she had
like fifteen thousand dollars on her
credit cards and I had credit cards that
had zero percent if I revolved it so I
took that put on my credit cards and
then for the next several years I paid
off her death that's nice view and heard
that her her and her dad you pay it all
so I they did you only took me for 20
grand well he's a man do you get married
no no [ __ ] no no just engaged he lost on
that ring to then you lost more money on
that ring to the ring was in there she
gave me the ring back it but you still
lose i lost i totally we lose on it was
on the novel six months later she came
back and asked if we could get married
like if we could start over again i
don't know what no
no I'm this is great now I'm stand up in
Hollywood labels doing sets on a Friday
night is ladies everywhere I'm good good
I had a bar I didn't have I still had I
still have we don't speak anymore
obviously but we have a cousin who we
found out later was gambling big time
online and he had taken a credit card
out my brother's name he had taken one
out my dead grandmother's name my dead
grandfather who had been dead since 73
why don't even know how does that happen
I think what happened with that was my
grandmother or just probably for you
know I don't know keepsake momenta
whatever kept his account alive so she
had to also she just liked having his
card so that way she had two sources if
it's an emergency she's looking credit
guys showing up at the cemetery will you
do what you do but I soon we don't want
to hear you moment but then I get a call
at my work and I'm like shut the [ __ ] up
I know exactly what this is about I
start telling the guy and he's like yeah
he's got you too so I have him arrested
Ilana you had him arrested I had to go
from what you have to how much money was
it uh I want to say somewhere between
four and five grand but probably for
each of us all in scattered across cars
Pablo authorities are doing this like
what were your relationship with him was
he fungi great yet we were always all
right so they always talk they're
actually they're always super living
together at the time of what happened
was he would get our mail before I would
get home so he got the application he
got my social norm he knew all the ant
what's your mother's maiden name he's my
first cousin he's his dad my dad were
brothers so he knew every answer to get
a credit card in our name everything and
did and then once we started figuring
out what was going on because at that
time i didn't know he i just thought he
was buying [ __ ] i didn't know he was
also gambling he's doing all right and
then i would suck living a lie he bought
my brother's a boring as I uh he bought
my brothers and tickets to a game and
stuff like you paid for those you
[ __ ] idiot you're paid for them
there's a nice but he so then I started
finding like
so we worked opposite schedules so I'm
up late one night and I see the VCR pop
on remember when you could set a timer
and I'm like wonder what this is i turn
on its this bookie like a TV book you
telling you what what games have been on
a Charlie over the nuns life's a good
show oh yeah you know late if that's
coming on late night TV you know it's
it's a good advice like a local-access
late night [ __ ] he don't hi me he'll do
about it clearly not going well and yes
so I have him arrested and that's when
we find out the full extent of it like I
didn't know he had had my gram I just
need my brother of me at that point but
then it got real real because it's all
you know this whole book easy hear about
these bookies and a collection and all
that's not real well I get a phone call
one day from a guy that says the Duke
wants is money that's my first reaction
was the land you know I thought my
body's attractive because they know that
shit's going on with whatever else I
like now the Duke wants his money I'm
like wait what book you the Duke and the
Duke wants his money if you don't give
his folk of money he's sending to my to
the house to get it oh my god and then a
couple days later [ __ ] to you on
Wayne we chose up [ __ ] doctor and
Earl comes by to dude show up at the
[ __ ] door he said a big they're big
and they want their [ __ ] money and he
sends his wife with a newborn in her
arms down to the door to get it because
he thinks they have hearts they won't
[ __ ] attack her he's upstairs hiding
like she told us all this later that
they come and they came twice he did not
have the money everything for us
obviously fell apart after that you know
we got out of there I got him already
did have the money it seems like a saber
they did nothing they won't these credit
card companies did nothing they slapped
him on the wrist and right now don't do
that again I'm my crazy seriously yeah
that's all they did they don't give a
[ __ ] they're like he'll run up some more
bills ism but wait he didn't get
arrested by anyone he got arrested here
so here's way it works you put a warrant
out for somebody and they can't go get
them for that right away they have to
wait until they [ __ ] up and [ __ ] ups
always [ __ ] up and he did he got I don't
know if it was
got pulled over for speeding or what it
was but as soon as they get you and they
see that there's a warrant out boom they
snag them was not long at all maybe a
month or two tops might even quicker
they get them they release him he has to
pay his bail and all that [ __ ] and then
i delayed my trip here to make sure
because i got the court-appointed
attorney i go to court he's an he's a
no-show and that guy was just like
listen man you do not need you can move
you don't need to wait here for this i
get it and he stayed in touch with me
while I ain't just told me is like they
didn't do [ __ ] they gave him a slap on
the wrist is told I'm like so
theoretically I could do this right now
and rack up a few grand in charges on
[ __ ] now when he's like I mean yeah he
didn't he was smart enough not to do a
shitload of money on each at each credit
card right he's a launch company it's
not worth them to pursue it that easily
because it cost them too much exactly
you stay under the limit and and they're
short for that [ __ ] anyway yeah they
don't care they didn't care if it would
have been crazy gratuitous then yes they
would have done something but so when
when he's arrested you're still living
with him no no I was still living in
maryland at the time I'm saying as soon
as we found out all this [ __ ] went down
we all moved out okay and then i would
say maybe a few weeks later I get to
call at work that hey Capital One's on
the phone you're late on payments and I
knew right away I'm like I don't even
have a car with them but everything that
happened I knew what it was and I got on
the phone tag I'm like look and the
idiot used his name and everything he
just gave them my work number and me is
like a cosigner on the thing and I'm
like why what a [ __ ] more I had all
the information I needed I mean mostly I
think we're finding out most robbers
here predominate most no dumber than the
teller at the bank but I mom yeah I
should probably use my real name he use
my work dress number i mean they called
me and they're like and they usually
wait like the same thing happened to my
brother he used his information and
where he was working was my friend's uh
business and they were like hey we got a
credit card company that keeps hounding
you here saying that you owe them money
my brothers like I don't even have a
credit card right now because we've just
gotten into college that's when i first
got that's what began all the credit
card debt trouble but ya he [ __ ] ran
him up did his divorce um
I I I don't know I think he'd she ended
up passing Young's I don't know if they
were taught a very divorce yes she died
was the answer or something like that so
I don't know if they were technically
divorced or separated or what at that
point is he still in touch with anyone
in your family his side I mean we don't
talk to any of them anymore we've run
into him twice we ran into him in a bar
in Baltimore City it was him my uncle in
my aunt's and everyone in the bar knows
us bartenders are all like ah you know
and they're all tough and I I'm calling
all my other cousin realize recyclers
what gets down here they're out here
right now and I thought they were trying
to get out of here they were hard and
they start yelling spin like my own was
yelling [ __ ] to my brother Kyle piss on
Your Grave I'm like what a piece of [ __ ]
so they have to leave and go down the
stairs and what you know it's like a you
know when there's a stairwell there's
like a area above it where you can look
down or spitting and dumped over your
[ __ ] on them while they go out all it
was great some somebody who's that my
dad from and then my other cousin is
who's now the retired cop comes I mean
he's speeding across the city to get
there he comes it all sweating out of
breath and were like you just don't
bring it up like i can't believe i
missed the boom we were at luby's medic
Eveleigh yeah people are [ __ ] [ __ ]
people are [ __ ] their [ __ ] and the
shitty ones always get away with it they
do they really [ __ ] to like that
connect i might almost father-in-law
totally [ __ ] got away with totally
got away with that yeah could you pay
paid the [ __ ] bag well he wouldn't
get his legs broken I'm sure my uncle
cleared the debt for him and everything
um I was stopped this times my slob but
that might be the thermostat could be
that it's an alarm it's an alarm of some
sort it's trying to tell someone did
something bad is happening don't worry
we'll let Dave and able and well listen
we are there man but thank you so much
for coming on and sharing you
or your your phantasm a crime story if
i'm standin that's a nice to have a
theme I don't have any way sometime yeah
we used to jump around yeah will you
want more time your podcast your social
media whatever you'd like oh yeah
they've advanced and podcast is the
dollop if you want your good stories
that's a podcast listen to it's all
stories and then my instagram is dave
underscore anthony underscore and my
twitter is at Dave Anthony so wait a min
Dave Anthony was taken and yet on the
scoring anything you know what I did is
also said I signed up and then I forgot
the password and there was at that time
no way to get free of it like there was
no I was [ __ ] is happening you can't
retrieve it and then I just gave up and
started a new one but I think I did that
twice because I kept signing up
annealing analyst I can do this and then
the third time I was like I should
probably start because it was on here
and then I was like I already took all
the names and I don't know what the
password toy Dave underscore Anthony
under school right and it's very
convenient it's great man thanks come a
nominee all thing in comedy the Daleks
definitely give it a listen as always
Jay Larson comic com Jay Larson comedy
on all social media Ryan sitcom Ryan
sicken all social media will talk to you
all next Tuesday